people are saying the debates could
swing the election
that's right Conan nerves are running
high and that's why I found a way to
take the edge off the debates tonight
it's a little thing I'm calling Andy's
debate drinking game
[Applause]
you can you guys can play this one at
home here are the rules
drink every time Donald Trump says the
word huge and then drink every time
someone says god Bless America and they
drink every time you see the color blue
drink every time your wife says hey
maybe you've had enough and you say no
maybe you've had enough and drink every
time the neighbors complain about the
noise and you respond by taking a giant
number two in your yard and then drink
every time you wake up realize you
passed out in said neighbor's yard Janis
and you throw like you throw in your
suit and you hurry to your unfulfilled
job okay and it's just curious what is
this exactly have to do with the debate
now drink every time someone asks you a
stupid question
[Applause]
and a yeah I think you've had enough and
then drink every time you walk in your
living room to watch the next debate and
all your friends or family are there but
they lock the door and they say you have
a problem drink every time you're about
to get thrown into a van and sent to
rehab which happens so often that you
start going around with a flask and your
rectum
so those sanctimonious bastards can't
keep you from your sweet food anywhere
we're all getting a little worried about
you you know worried why we're all
having fun enjoy my goddamn drinking
game and these debate drinking game
[Applause]
you